in 2008's the Dark Knight director
Christopher Nolan used 70 millimeter
IMAX cameras to give his pictures a
distinct look and feel no matter if it's
Wally Fister or hoita van hoytema who
has shot every Nolan picture from
Interstellar onwards behind the camera
the oturf filmmaker has kept his
signature cinematic look no wonder he
has been tasked with helping design the
next set of IMAX cameras Oppenheimer
follows Nolan's style shooting on a
combination of imax's 65 millimeter and
65 millimeter large format cameras in
addition to using multiple IMAX bodies
this time around Nolan's latest feature
also utilized imax's first attempt at
black and white photography the director
told total film we challenged the people
at Kodak and photochem to make this work
for us for the first time ever we were
able to shoot IMAX film in black and
white and the results were thrilling and
extraordinary as soon as hoida and I saw
the first tests come in we just knew
that this was a format that we were
immediately in love with